les deux communautés les plus réticents
à la vaccination sont la communauté
religieuse ultra orthodoxes et la
communauté arabe
le gouvernement et les autorités sont en
contact avec les dirigeants de ces
communautés et envoie également des
centres de vaccination mobile
littéralement au coeur de ces
communautés
lorsque le centre de vaccination et
devant la porte de quelqu'un il est bien
plus simple de se faire vacciner
le passeport vert qui est délivrée après
avoir reçu deux doses du vaccin est
également une incitation forte
il ya des contrôles de ces passeports
vert à l'entrée d'hôtels de restaurants
et de concerts ce qui pousse beaucoup de
personnes a souhaité se faire vacciner
enfin la fête juive de pessah débute
samedi soir à la même période l'année
dernière
des gens passaient pessah chez eux sans
pouvoir se réunir en famille l'idée de
pouvoir se rassembler en famille pour
les nombreuses fêtes juives et donc
également un facteur de motivation
les israéliens reprennent ouvertement
leur vie normale
l'aéroport qui était fermé pendant la
majeure partie du mois a rouvert et les
vols internationaux au départ et à
l'arrivée ont repris même si les
arrivants doivent toujours passé une
semaine d'isolement chez eux ou dans un
hôtel s'ils n'ont pas reçu les deux
doses du vaccin les salles de sport sont
ouvertes à 70 % c'est-à-dire qu'elle
opère à une jauge de 70%
mais pour se rendre à un concert un
événement culturel ou au restaurant
il faut présenter un passeport vert j'ai
moi même voulu réserver une table au
restaurant hier et tout était complet
pour les deux semaines à venir
les israéliens n'ont donc pas perdu de
temps pour retrouver le pays et leur vie
d'avant le coronavirus country le
passeport vert n'est valide que pour six
mois et on ne sait pas ce qui se passe
après six mois
il n'y a pas eu de décision officielle
ou en tout cas pas de déclaration par le
ministère de la santé où le premier
ministre mais on pense qu'il y aura des
rappels à prendre dans les six mois
c'est un sujet que le pays va devoir
étudier en profondeur dans l'intervalle
et ça approche ainsi que le jour de
l'indépendance et yom hashoah la journée
du souvenir pour la première fois depuis
longtemps il y aura de grands
rassemblements en extérieur pour ces
événements mais israël maintient
toujours le port du masque et la
distanciation physique donc cela au
moins là resté pendant longtemps